[Music]
Ariana Maddox living her best life at
Coachella with a new man I'm doing the
things I need to do to take care of
myself
six weeks after Scandal broke the
Vanderpump rule star hit up the music
festival with fitness trainer Daniel y
the two spotted getting cozy dancing
together multiple times
[Music]
what I do
Ariana also shared Polaroids with him
and her friends and video of her getting
a tattoo
an eyewitness tells E.T Daniel was there
to support the reality star as she got
the new Inc saying the pair seemed
comfortable together as they stood arm
and arm before Ariana consulted the
tattoo artist that's awesome so who's
Ariana's new bow well a source tells ET
she and Daniel met at a mutual friend's
wedding in Mexico his website reveals
he's a New York native LinkedIn notes
he's a Virginia Tech Alum and his day
job a physical trainer
our source says Daniel's a sweet guy and
it seems to us Ariana is pretty Smitten
by him everybody went through a lot of
emotions honestly I think that makes for
a great season for people to watch when
it's really difficult to film this all
comes as fans continue to watch the
dramatic end of Ariana and Tom
Sandoval's relationship play out on the
Bravo show following his cheating
scandal with co-star Raquel Levis
once acting weird I'm just trying to
live my life and I'm sorry if that
offends people but it's not going to
stop me from doing what I want to do the
aftermath no doubt dissected during the
pump rules reunion which taped March
23rd and gave Ariana a chance to show
off this Revenge dress people are coming
up to us asking about Ariana's Revenge
dress everyone's talking about it I was
on the street with Anderson Cooper
yesterday and someone came up to ask us
about the Revenge dress he's like what's
going on right now yeah Bravo King Andy
Cohen teases the season 10 reunion is
packed with drama it's the Reckoning
that I think people are looking for
um and it was it was very
confrontational and it was I feel like
everything there was nothing left unsaid
I just think that there was more
um how different was it it there was
just so much on the table that needed to
be and everyone had things to say that
being said
I've now done you know hundreds of
reunions so yeah I would say this is
going to be this is going to be top ten
I think the fans will be satisfied yes I
do you want anything
for you to die
[Music]